le pouvoir d'achat c'est un peu comme la
météo il y a les températures et le
ressenti l'insee estime que le pouvoir
d'achat est en hausse de 2,1 pour cent
en 2019
mais pour beaucoup de français ici à
strasbourg les comptes ne sont pas bons
certains affirment eux que les 100 de
moi sont toujours aussi difficiles et
cela malgré les nombreuses mesures
prises par le gouvernement des manuels
macron à savoir la suppression
progressive de la taxe d'habitation ou
encore la baisse de 5 milliards d'impôts
sur le revenu ils ont que la vie
augmente on se rend compte le pain le le
courant au marché on voit que les prix
d'une année sur l'autre augmente
un petit peu les timbres l'électricité
enfin bon le tout ce qu'on entend on a
besoin actuellement
on arrive quand même donc avoir quelques
difficultés fin du mois et du coup on
fait attention quand même par rapport
aux prix et
voilà tout le monte en termes de
factures de gaz électricité
quand on regarde tous les prélèvements
en ce moment a pas vraiment l'impression
d'être plus riche qu'avant j'ai jamais
vérifier les prix de ma vie mais depuis
je suis retraité oui je vérifie
absolument tout et je vais toujours au
moins cher un pouvoir d'achat en déclin
un sentiment qui prédomine dans cette
ville de strasbourg et il est exacerbé
dans les locaux des restos du coeur
association qui vient en aide à près de
13000 personnes dans le bas rhin
parmi elles l'yonne qui témoignent à
visage couvert
à 42 ans son seul objectif est de
nourrir ses deux enfants
ses loisirs personnels elle a mis une
croix dessus je matin sur les priorités
nous reste je me dis que ce n'est
qu'accessoire quoi qu'est ce que par
exemple vous pouvez pas vous acheter par
exemple mes propres dans mes propres
besoins
se faire plaisir comme toutes les dames
je peux pas le faire vous pouvez pas
aller chez le coiffeur je peux pas aller
chez le coiffeur comme je peux
comme je le faisais avant et le cinéma
c'est non pas du tout
non jamais non je suis jamais arrivé que
je suis en france le fameux frire pour
moi c'est un luxe quoi beaucoup je le
mets de côté puis je m'en sens
nécessaire livres aux journaux zurichois
l'histoire de l'yonne est loin d'être un
cas isolé et bénévole depuis près de 23
ans léa on a vu bien d'autres
il ya 23 ans on avait moins de personnes
donc vous donner plus
chaque semaine il avait à nouveau des
nouveaux des nouvelles personnes qui
sont là qui ont besoin et tout ça ça
augmente voiliers et puis bon bain
malheureusement
ça ne s'arrange pas quand vous voyez que
vous avez eu des parents qui me dit il
avait des enfants de 10 12 ans 14h15 ans
et maintenant ces enfants qui viennent
chercher des aux restos du coeur
moi ça me fait ça me touche quand même
parce que je me dis ça ne devrait plus
exister ce genre nation une détresse
financière qui se propage au plus grand
nombre
un français sur deux affirme recourir
aux découverts bancaires pour boucler
ses fins de mois
[Musique]